David Chalmers is a professor of
philosophy and Neuroscience at New York
University and an honorary professor of
philosophy at the Australian National
University he's co-director of the
center for mind brain and Consciousness
as well as the Phil papers Foundation
his research focuses on the philosophy
of Mind especially consciousness of
course and its connection to Fields such
as cognitive science physics and
Technology he also investigates areas
such as the philosophy of language
metaphysics and epistemology with his
impressive breadth of knowledge and
experience David Chalmers is a leader in
the philosophical community
so there has been all this controversy
and debate recently about whether
language models might be conscious and
I've actually been especially interested
in
not so much people's gut intuitions one
way or the other but the reasons and the
evidence on both sides first what is the
evidence that these language models
might be conscious and second what is
the evidence of the reasons for saying
they're not conscious when it comes to
the reasons in favor there are a few
things there uh well it's you can get
these systems to say they're conscious
on the other hand you can also get these
systems to say they're not conscious
so it's not clear what weight that
carries for me actually the most
strongest consideration in favor of
Consciousness in these systems is
they're showing signs of general
intelligence the ability to do many
things
in the study of Consciousness we take
the domain General use of information to
be one marker of Consciousness maybe
that's maybe one
strike in favor
when it comes to reasons against there
are many many objections that people
have raised one objection is that these
language models aren't biological and
biology is required to be conscious I
mean that would be a very general reason
that would prevent any artificial
Consciousness so I end up setting that
one aside but there are many other
reasons I say what is the X
such that
you need X to be conscious and these
large language models don't have X well
besides biology there's maybe having
senses and a body right now language
models don't have sensors don't have a
body on the other hand it's not terribly
difficult people have already built
extensions of these language models call
them Vision language action models that
deal with sensory information in the
form of images
and which control a body may be hooked
up to a robot body or a virtual body so
I think in this case it looks like even
if the large language models May lack
what's required for Consciousness these
extended versions what I call LOM pluses
extended large language models might
overcome those objections and I think
there are a series of objections to
language models that take the same form
people argue that they don't have World
models
or self models people argue they don't
have recurrent processing or a global
workspace maybe most deeply they don't
seem right now to be unified agents with
fundamental goals of their own but all
of these seem to be to be temporary
issues maybe today's language models
lack them but tomorrow's extended
language models May well have all of
these properties they may have World
models and self models
they may have recurrent processing and a
global workspace they may even have
unified agency so I think there's a
research program here of trying to build
AI systems that have all those X's which
are currently missing from large
language models and then the question is
just say we build within say 10 years or
so a system which has all of those X's
it needn't even be human level
intelligence maybe just will have
something like fish level cognition or
intelligence because you know most
people think fish are conscious just say
we build a system like that that has the
uh the sensors the body if only a
virtual body
the uh the world models and the self
models the recurrent processing the
global workspace the unified agency will
it then be conscious we might have these
systems by say 2032 10 years or so some
people are going to say those systems
are not conscious if so I ask them
what's missing
interesting but but for Charmers
um this conscious experience it what's
the cash value of it well exactly I've
never managed to work that out uh and um
that contradicts human
first person accounts
another maybe interesting question is
one you prompted with the AGI comments
so to what extent do you think
Consciousness is a necessary condition
for AGI assuming one can achieve it or
could one get to AGI without the
Consciousness path it's a really
interesting question and this you know
this interacts with the question of the
philosopher zombie the system which has
all the behavior of a human being but
none of the Consciousness I've argued
that zombies are at least conceivable we
can imagine a system that behaves like
us without Consciousness but that
doesn't mean that such a system could
actually exist in this world I'm
inclined to think that in this world
intelligent intelligence and
Consciousness go very tightly together I
mean
maybe there are some systems my uh my
colleague Ned block has considered the
idea of a giant lookup table that stores
every possible conversation passes the
Turing test that would not possibly be
conscious my own view is that uh is
there any
system with reasonable mechanisms that
generates human-like
intelligent Behavior will probably be
conscious but if it turns out that you
know that maybe massive scaling yields
poor pure feed forward Transformers with
Incredible capabilities but no
consciousness I mean that's not
something I can totally rule out I do
think this is a potential concern if
you're thinking about the role of AI in
the future that we're going to have
if it's possible that we're gonna have
beings which are highly intelligent
which lack Consciousness entirely then
their role with respect to say moral
social legal issues is going to be very
delicate and hard to adjudicate
philosophical zombies are imaginary
beings that are physically and
behaviorally indistinguishable from
conscious humans yet lack conscious
experience
this concept has been used to explore
the implications of certain thought
experiments such as the Chinese room
argument which posits that a computer
program can pass the Turing test yet
still lack consciousness
to build a zombie one could imagine a
cabinet full of raw materials from which
to construct a perfect copy of a human
all memory knowledge and personality
would be embedded into the physical
system and the Clone would behave as if
it were conscious however our intuition
tells us that when the parts were
unassembled there would be no
consciousness present
the concept of a philosophical zombie
has been widely discussed in the
philosophical literature yet there is no
consensus on the matter
proponents of the idea of a
philosophical zombie suggests that if
such a being were possible it would
suggest that Consciousness is an
emerging property of certain physical
systems and not an intrinsic property of
the universe this would have
implications for how we understand the
nature of Consciousness and its
relationship to physical systems
opponents of the idea of a physical
zombie point out that there's no
empirical evidence that such a being
could exist
they argue that if there was a
philosophical zombie then a physical
system that is behaviorally and
physically indistinguishable from a
conscious human would still lack
consciousness
this would suggest that Consciousness is
an intrinsic property of the universe
and not an emergent property of certain
physical systems
the debate over the concept of a
philosophical zombie continues to rage
in the philosophical Community while
it's unclear that this issue will ever
be resolved anytime soon it's an
intriguing concept that has been used to
explore the relationship between
Consciousness and physical systems
the zombie is a system which has you
know all the uh the intelligence and the
outward behavior of a human being but
not of the Consciousness and the thought
is you know relevant here in New Orleans
it's like wouldn't it be a drag to be a
zombie of none of the uh none of the
experience of a uh of a human being so
it goes I act like you act
I do what you do
but I don't know what it's like to be
you
what Consciousness is I ain't got a clue
I got the zombie Blues
for a very long time philosophers and
scientists have shared a common interest
in and puzzlement over the hard problem
of consciousness
physicality seems insufficient to be the
source of the subjective coherent
experience that we call consciousness
David Chalmers invented the phrase the
hard problem in an attempt to describe
this very phenomenon
finding a way to link mental states to
neurophysiological activity is the hard
problem in a nutshell
it's beyond the scope of human inquiry
to determine why it is that any kind of
physical action should and presumably
does give rise to subjective experience
consider the hypothetical situation of
two sets of identical twins you have the
same DNA upbringing and educational
experiences the twins will have quite
distinct subjective experiences of the
world this exemplifies the challenge of
explaining how subjective sensation may
result from objective physical action
now you might just counter and say this
example is simply a matter of complexity
however the Chinese room argument is
another thought experiment which might
shed light on the hard problem of
consciousness
in this hypothetical scenario a person
is locked in a room and given a series
of instructions and symbols and an
external Observer is provided the output
after the individual has been requested
to modify the symbols in accordance with
the instructions
now despite the fact that the individual
in the room is manipulating symbols the
thought experiment shows that he doesn't
understand since he does not have the
requisite phenomenal experience
Consciousness is a hard problem that has
been discussed for Millennia but never
resolved some say that it simply can't
be done while others think that a mix of
Neuroscience philosophy and psychology
will eventually get us there no matter
what the solution to the hard problem of
Consciousness is it's clear that it's a
difficult problem to solve
I started this uh
my original title for the talk is the
word sentience in the end I decided that
word is just too confusing even more
confusing than the word Consciousness so
I went with uh with Consciousness
instead but as I use the terms those two
things abruptly equivalent Consciousness
is sentience which is subjective
experience
being is conscious
in the philosopher Thomas Nagel's phrase
if there's something it's like to be
that being
if that being has subjective experience
like the experience of seeing of feeling
of thinking
wrote a famous article called what is it
like to be a bat where he says that you
know it's very hard to know exactly what
a bad subjective experience is like when
it's using Sonar to get around
nevertheless most of us believe there is
something it's like to be about it is
conscious it has subjective experience
on the other hand most people think
there's nothing it's like to be let's
say a water bottle the bottle does not
have subjective experience it's not
conscious
now it's clear that the modern human has
a huge problem with not knowing there'll
always be a tension between having a
theory of the world in hand which makes
excellent scientific predictions but
which bucks against our evolved
intuitions John Locke Emanuel Kant and
John Rose all have argued that an
intelligible framework is necessary for
humans to make moral and rational
decisions such a framework provides us
with a sense of stability and order as
well as a sense of meaning and purpose
Nietzsche however questioned the role of
the personality of the philosopher in
his own philosophy he argued that the
innermost drives of a philosopher's
nature can shape their morality
suggesting that the search for a New
Foundation of values knowledge and
beliefs must come from within the
individual
in his essay what's it like to be a bat
Thomas Nagel considers this subject from
the vantage point of a bat
since our experiences are so different
he says we can never really comprehend
what it's like to be a bat since bats
use echolocation rather than vision
Nagel claims that their perception of
the world is fundamentally different
from our own the bat he says has a much
richer sensory experience than we do
because it can pick up on a wide variety
of objects and surfaces many more so
than we can
since our experiences are so different
from our bats Nagel concludes that we
can never know what it's like to be one
according to him the only way to know
what it's like to be a bat is to become
one which is obviously not conceivable
he believes that we can only do our best
to Envision what it's like to be a bat
and to fly around the world
Nagel's inconceivability argument has
its advantages and disadvantages on the
one hand it's a great way to test the
boundaries of our knowledge
understanding the world is more
complicated requires admitting that
there are certain things that we just
can't fathom
however the inconceivability argument
might be seen as a barrier to our human
ability to comprehend the universe at
all much like how Noam Chomsky said that
rats would be unable to solve the prime
number maze accepting that there are
certain things which we will never be
able to grasp May prevent us from
understanding and expanding our
frontiers of knowledge
the most significant and defining
quality of mental phenomena is
consciousness making it impossible to
solve the mind-body problem it's
impossible to comprehend the material
foundations of Mind fire reductionist
theories since they ignore the
subjective nature of things
this subjective nature is linked to a
particular point of view and cannot be
represented by reductionist theories
exploring the topic in the context of an
example which highlights the difference
between subjective and objective
conceptions is useful for illustrating
the relationship between subjectivity
and making visible the relevance of
subjective qualities
the bat is used by Nagel because it
exemplifies the difficulty of the
subjective nature of experience by
providing a spectrum of activity and
sensory experience so different from
ours that it's particularly striking
now since the raw material of our
imagination comes from our own
experiences its scope is necessarily
truncated we can't infer the bat's inner
existence from our own and if we attempt
to Envision what it's like to be a bat
all we have is our own limited mental
capacity
nothing in our current makeup allows us
to contemplate what it might be like to
exist in the state of interpolated
Badness even if such a transformation
were theoretically possible
so while we may make some assumptions
about what it must be like to be a bat
based on our own understanding of the
animal's anatomy and behavior we
recognize that each individual bats
experience must have a unique subjective
quality which is beyond our cognitive
Horizon
some scientific realities May defy
description even in the broadest terms
of Human Experience most people can't
fathom the nature of a person's
experience who's been deaf and blind
from birth even sentient bats or
martians from another planet would have
a pretty hard time imagining what it's
like to be human it's possible for us to
have faith in the reality of things
whose precise nature we can't yet fathom
but reality may be known from just one
vantage point it's unclear how the
organism's physiology May somehow convey
the underlying nature of experiences
to simplify is to advance towards more
objectivity a precise understanding of
the true essence of things it's not
clear what's meant by objective nature
right the objective nature of an
experience if it's not understood in
relation to the subject's unique
perspective even a scientist from Mars
who's never seen a rainbow a bolt of
lightning or a cloud Nagel said couldn't
miss the fact that they're all examples
of physical events Lightning's objective
nature is not depleted by its outward
form a more direct link seems to exist
between one's experiences and their
beliefs we don't characterize the world
around us in terms of specific
Sensations or our senses take away from
it but rather in terms of the broad
impacts it has and the traits which may
be detected by methods other than the
human senses we feel that the more our
representation doesn't rely on a human
or anthropocene trick perspective it
kind of becomes more objective it's
conceivable to forsake an
anthropocentric perspective in favor of
something more abstract while
maintaining the same understanding Nagel
said that not all experiences follow the
pattern of relinquishing a subjective
experience in favor of a more objective
one in order to better comprehend the
same events because it is fundamental to
The Human Experience the uniqueness of
the human Viewpoint is something which
we can't ignore indefinitely modern
psychology's behaviorist approach may be
traced back to an attempt to replace
subjective mental experience with
something more scientifically rigorous
like a theory of Mind there must be some
essential similarity between going
through certain physical processes and
having a thought occur in your head if
thoughts are actually physical processes
Nagel said that the failure of
physicalist ideas which rest on an
incorrect kind of like objective
examination of Mind proves nothing due
to our lack of a conceptual framework
physicalism remains an incomprehensible
Viewpoint to him
Nagel said we should try to develop an
objective phenomenology not dependent on
empathy or our imagination I mean if you
were to describe what it's like to see
to someone who's been blind their entire
life you would use this phenomenology
perception structural properties May
lend themselves to a dispassionate
analysis to get some insight of our own
experience it's important to build
Notions which are distinct from those
which we acquire via first person
learning or experience
Nagel concluded that the insights into
the physical substrate of experience may
be made possible by an objective
phenomenology
so I'll just uh
talk about language models in general
which the topic I don't need to
introduce
to this crowd typically these are going
to be with Transformer architecture
multi-head self-attention gpt3 is still
um the best known one but uh I take it
gpt4 any day now people I'll also talk
about uh extended large language models
extensions of what I'll call llm classes
these are models that add further
capacities to the pure text or language
capacities of a language model now there
are very familiar Vision language models
that add image processing language
action models that add control of a
physical or a virtual body
there are large language models extended
with things like code execution
database queries
simulations and so on and in many ways
I'm interested in not so much not just
the large language models today but the
capacities of the systems that may be
developed in the coming years which will
include these llm plus models
and my questions will be questions like
well first our current
large language models plausibly
conscious but maybe even more
importantly could future large language
models and extensions thereof
be conscious
and what challenges need to be overcome
on the path to conscious machine
learning systems
I really see this I mean there are
challenges here and there are objections
but I really want to think of this also
as a constructive project one that might
ultimately leave to a potential road map
to Consciousness Nai systems so the
thing I've sometimes seen characters in
GPT models do is sometimes it's
something strange happens in the story
like you know you have some stories and
characters and then suddenly saying you
know the model the size in a you know
refrigerator token is selected
refrigerant characters will notice that
as sometimes they'll question whether
they are a simulation the the characters
aerogeneity generate storm will be like
this is just a simulation you know am I
real and stuff like this in a way how
does this relates to the idea of con
stimulation are the characters inside of
gbt potentially the generals are
entities that have some amount of money
or practice so um David I had dinner
with Connolly he on Friday night and
he's one of the founders of a life for
AI and they famously recreated gpt3 type
language models which is to say you know
these statistical Auto regressive
self-attention Transformers models which
is a bit of a mouthful uh trained on a
bunch of internet text and um some of
their models are pretty large actually
they just released a 22 billion
parameter version called gbt Neo X now
Conor really likes to think that gbt3 is
an example of general intelligence he's
a True Believer and therefore convinced
that we should be concerned with AI
alignment as a top priority he said
something which really fascinated me
which relates to your book reality plus
he said that in many of the fictional
stories that he's generated of gbt3 the
characters sometimes becomes self-aware
that they're in a simulation if you like
so when they see an unexpected word in
the sequence
um you know they they kind of have that
realization that that they're in a
simulation of reality so it's kind of
glitchy and the simulated residents are
aware of the glitches so I think in all
likelihood Conor has an overactive
imagination but I thought it was a
fascinating thought when I spoke with
Keith about it yesterday he said it
reminded him of the idea of being Fooled
by Randomness there is a famous example
with the ghosts in Pac-Man many years
ago where people were convinced that
there was some kind of intelligent
Behavior and the ghosts were
coordinating with each other which
actually turned out not to be the case
at all so I think one of the themes of
our conversation today will be intention
versus extension or causal structure
versus correlation you know which is to
say this idea that just because
something appears to be conscious or
intelligent in its physical
configuration of the output doesn't mean
it necessarily is
so gpt3 conscious or not
um
I uh you know I'm open to the idea
there's Consciousness even in very
simple systems you know like even the uh
the worm like one of these basic
um C elegans it has uh 300 neurons uh
it's sensitive tonight to light it
engages in simple action and so on I'm
at least open to the idea that that worm
has some element very simple element of
Consciousness and then you've got to ask
yourself if a worm with a
300 neurons
can possibly be conscious what about
gbg3 with
100 billion plus
uh parameters it's so much more complex
than the worm there's so much going on
it has so many
capacities to do uh to communicate uh to
talk to uh to reason even to uh to
explain you might think okay well if a
worm is conscious
then gpt3 has got some element of
Consciousness too on the other hand
gpt3 is not very much like an agent you
know it's not a it's not a doesn't
correspond to a person that has
consistent beliefs or desires or actions
I mean it's more of a chameleon ride
because you can you can set up your
prompt engineering on gpt3 to get it to
take on any kind of persona you like uh
with any set of you know beliefs and
desires that you like so maybe gpg3 is
not so much like an agent or a person
but a meta agent that can take on many
different forms depending on exactly how
it's engineered I mean I would not be
inclined to think that right now gbt3
has anything like say the consciousness
of a uh of a human being that would
require a kind of coherence and unified
intelligence right now I think is beyond
gpt3 but does it have some basic element
of Consciousness I certainly wouldn't
rule that out
well I so I I think we would agree
though and and you said this explicitly
in the book that there's no reason not
to believe that it will be possible at
some point for Consciousness to be in
silico
um is that true and so what I want to
try and do is bring the the zomb The
Perennial zombie question the
philosophical zombie into the context of
of reality Plus or a simulation and my
question is this and it's really about
trying to find the uh the explanation
for Consciousness so suppose as a result
of us posting this video here
um you know the Architects whoever
created this the simulation that we're
in they watch the video and they say I
think it's about time to have a little
chat with uh with David and they come to
you in a in a dream because they can do
that and they present to you evidence
that you're convinced that you are
actually conversing with with the
Architects they explain look uh you guys
are actually running on this neutron
star super computer that we built and
and by the way we so happen to still use
C code and they show you the the C code
for for agents in this world for people
here's all the C code that's running
your brain and your neurons and
everything and this module over here and
they show you a module source code and
they say this is the Consciousness
module now not everybody's running this
in fact you have one running but a lot
of people we don't bother installing
them and they're just actually zombies
because we didn't attach you know this
this conscious this module to them but
you're you're running a Consciousness
module would you accept that that bit of
code you know however long it is this
module 500 lines 10 000 lines would you
accept that that code explains
consciousness
I would really need to know what their
evidence is and what their what their
science is I mean maybe
uh these beings could convince me that I
am actually part of a of a simulation if
they presented the code for the
simulation and they uh they did amazing
stuff there were messages in the sky
they turned the Empire State Building
which is right outside my window if they
turned it up they turned it upside down
in the uh in the sky then maybe that
would be pretty good evidence I'm in a
simulation I mean it wouldn't be totally
conclusive maybe they've just given me
some great drugs or uh maybe my whole
life had been in reality but just for a
moment just for tonight they put me into
a virtual reality that was totally
convincing and presented me with all
this fake evidence of turning the Empire
State Building upside down so I don't
know if it would be totally convincing
but yeah I think I could probably get
pretty good evidence that I'm in a
simulation but then you're telling me
okay now they've got some Theory Of
Consciousness they think that they've
put a uh a Consciousness module into me
but not into uh into some other beings
but then I interact with those beings
and they're they're perfectly normal I
don't know if those beings actually say
tell me that they're conscious
I'm gonna be inclined to uh to believe
them just as I do with other human
beings so if they tell me that they
think that these beings are
philosophical zombies beings that lacka
that lack Consciousness I'm Gonna Wanna
Know Why merely programming a merely
programming the beings isn't going to
tell us that we're going to need a
theory of Consciousness for that
I mean it's really important in these
discussions maybe I should have done
this to start with to distinguish
Consciousness and let's say intelligence
intelligence is all about you know
behavioral capacities the things you can
do carrying on a conversation taking
place uh sophisticated goal directed
action and so on but intelligence here
is objective it's something you can
measure from the objective point of view
ultimately coming down to behavioral
capacities whereas consciousness
as I understand it is subjective
Consciousness is a matter of how things
feel from the inside when I carry on
this conversation I can see you guys I
have some visual subjective experience
of you
I can hear you I can hear the sound of
my own voice I can feel my body I got
thoughts running through my head that's
all the subjective experience of
Consciousness so you know it may well be
that take gpt3 it's got rather
sophisticated capacities for
intelligence already but it is totally
unclear whether it's conscious whether
it has subjective experience maybe it
has a bit and the trouble is of course
well intelligence is very easy to
operationalize and measure from the
outside
Consciousness is not and you can
illustrate that with the with the idea
of the uh the philosophical zombie which
is behaving in extremely sophisticated
ways but has no subjective experience on
the inside I don't actually believe in
philosophical zombies in the sense I
don't think that there are
uh intelligent beings without
Consciousness around us but I do think
it's a coherent
hypothesis and that does mean that
whenever we create say an artificial
intelligence
with
uh with very sophistic even very
sophisticated intelligence you're always
going to be able to raise the question
is it conscious
of that question we need a theory of
Consciousness okay but the scenario here
though was you've you've been convinced
by these you know beings that they are
actually The Architects of the simulator
and they're literally showing you the
source code for the Consciousness module
but I think what you're telling me is
you still wouldn't believe it unless
they presented you with a theory that
you could personally understand yeah
well I think that being a good simulator
makes you a good theorist of
Consciousness I could you know maybe
potentially I could build a great
Universe simulation eventually and
simulate brains really well and so on
that doesn't mean that I've suddenly
solved the problem of Consciousness I'm
still going to know you know which bit
which processes in the brain or
elsewhere correspond to Consciousness
and what merely being a great simulation
engineer doesn't yet turn you into a
turn you into a scientist okay once
we've got those simulations of brains
end of the world and so on maybe they'll
be amazing things we can do to try and
you know put these systems in different
circumstances see how they behave see
when they respond see which kind of
simulations actually report being
conscious and maybe we could use that as
really great data for a theory of
Consciousness but I don't think it
suddenly resolves a problem just being
able to build a say a brain simulation
introduce himself to me and he tells me
you have a profound philosophical
analysis of Consciousness and well yeah
they've been doing at your school so I
just want to very much encourage you to
keep going with this project and see if
you can help us figure out the nature of
Consciousness I'm looking forward to
your future career as a philosopher he
brought in a thesis yes also from Ilias
is this Twitter thing because either
your daughter brought the uh the tweet
from yeah yeah yeah because it's my
thing from AI said why not start with
this and that was the same kind of
starting to think yeah and now it
becomes really uh uh interesting for the
philosophers because now it has a I will
say AI it has some actuality and stuff I
think it's a really cool topic now you
and your daughter have found something
and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you can collectively figure out AI
classes yeah I know we don't know how to
approach it because it's it's really a
hard topic to Define it because I'm was
a math guy
and it's not so well defined and
therefore I don't like it
uh what don't you like so definitions of
qualia Consciousness and quality yeah
and you need an operational definition
yeah in terms of input and output yeah
yeah give me something I can hand off to
my engineer yeah yeah
I would like it I understand the
Instinct yes I did put forward a call
for Consciousness benchmarks but yeah if
we had some common bit I don't think
you're going to find an uncontroversial
Benchmark but even having a few
different benchmarks for different kinds
or aspects or theories no that's
absolutely right yeah yeah I agree I
agree then we can yeah train up more and
more systems get closer and closer on
those benchmarks and then we can argue
about whether they're conscious what's
the subjectiveness uh here uh you cannot
look into another thing and that's uh
you only it's a secondary uh
measurements exactly that's make it
makes it hard but it would be a lot
easier if we had the Consciousness meter
I'd just wave it in your head yeah
searching for Consciousness yeah exactly
searching for consciousness
okay they're accepts Consciousness but
we don't have this this but physics is
the same you don't see atoms you don't
see other stuff yeah service reasonable
David can I just start with a question
which is that um a lot of your arguments
about the existence of intelligence are
based on functionalism which is to say
if it's similar to if you read a book by
Peter norved it says oh I'm an
intelligent system has planning it has
reasoning it has sensing it has
perception therefore it's intelligent
and and I I feel that this is a form of
behaviorism but a slightly more
sophisticated form of behavior
behaviorism and then I feel that some of
this has been projected into
um I think your your conversation the
other day on Consciousness which is to
say
um first of all could we have a Turing
test for Consciousness but also could we
have a functional approach to define
whether something is conscious and the
thing is I'm I'm a little bit my
intuition is to be skeptical of this but
I have to be completely honest I have no
principled way of describing why I'm
skeptical about it so if you could play
Devil's Advocate how would you attack
your own position on that functional
um view well I actually make a
distinction between
consciousness
and intelligence
um intelligence is a matter of the
outputs you produce given any input
especially goal directed Behavior the
ability to solve problems Consciousness
is the subjective experience
so and you know when it comes to
Consciousness the easy problems are
explaining the behavior the reactions
the hard problem is explaining
subjective experience so actually start
by drawing the distinction
that you want to draw between say
experience and function that said
when it comes to Consciousness in other
people
our we don't have direct evidence of
their Consciousness or we can go by is
their functioning and so in general what
another person says is evidence
of their Consciousness if you tell me
that you're conscious at a given time or
even if you show a certain sophisticated
reactive Behavior to a certain stimulus
we'll usually take that as evidence that
you are that you are conscious so I'd
say that yeah the view I was arguing the
other day was not that we should define
consciousness as some function but we
should look for those functions which
are the best evidence of Consciousness
in other people but also in animals and
ultimately in AI systems would it be
fair to say that you would argue that
it's a sufficient condition but not a
necessary condition
function is a sufficient condition for
experience yeah I mean not sufficient
across the board and the famous
philosophical zombie will be a creature
which has all the functioning indeed but
none of the uh none of the experience so
that's at least conceivable but my own
view is that those systems can't exist
in the real world so in the real world
certain kinds of functioning may be
sufficient conditions for a
Consciousness the the coin of the realm
in this science of human consciousness
is verbal report someone says they're
conscious you believe them unless
there's reason to believe otherwise or
they say they're conscious of a given
stimulus but humans we know are
conscious
makes it easier uh non-human animals are
already tricky at least they're related
to us so we think we've got some grounds
for this but AI systems we start from
the position of being totally unsure of
whether they're conscious or not so you
know Turing had the genius of proposing
at least one sufficient condition
behaving just like a human yes to me
that would be good enough yes
fascinating but what shorter that
actually counts then we start to argue
yes indeed indeed well um I mean with
the functionalism it's it's really
interesting how much of it is to do with
human intelligibility rather than the
actual thing which exists
um I feel that a lot of it is taking
something which is very complex and
beyond our cognitive Horizon and
creating or reducing it to a to a
cognitive framework which is compatible
with with the templates that we have in
in our own brains Consciousness itself
is yeah very mysterious and subjective
and on the other hand our tools for
understanding the brain are mostly
cognitive and informational but they do
seem to be of strong correlations at
least between the two you replicate all
that informational or cognitive
structure you replicate the brain you
will replicate Consciousness yes so the
two seem to be tied together what we
need to do is find the neural correlates
of Consciousness those bits of the brain
that seem to go along with being
Consciousness being conscious and maybe
even more fundamentally the you know the
informational correlates of
Consciousness the very general
mechanisms that support Consciousness
and then if we find the informational
correlate say of consciousness
in human beings maybe then we can
project those to AI systems see what we
do know very well the informational
properties of an AI system try to build
an AI system that has the right kind of
informational properties to serve as an
informational or a computational
correlative Consciousness then we might
have some evidence that it's conscious
it still won't be conclusive because how
do we know for sure whether that is in
fact the computational or informational
correlative Consciousness but there
would be some evidence if you could say
something to Ilia right now
what would you say
well I want him to define the scale of
Consciousness for us if neural networks
are going to be slightly conscious then
fantastic that means we've got a we've
got a scale and Ellie's a smart guy so I
want to see his definition of the
mathematical scale and the mathematical
structure of Consciousness so that so
that uh so that these uh neural networks
come in at the a certain Epsilon I
myself am quite sympathetic with the
idea that Consciousness could run very
deep in nature if pan sarcasm is true
nothing is at zero yes even particles
have got a little bit
on that measure the today's neural
networks even yesterday's neural
networks were slightly conscious today's
neural networks Maybe
slightly and a bit unconscious the
problem with pan psychism is it's such a
parsimonious and beautiful Theory
um we've just done a show on the Chinese
room argument and in in the simplest
possible terms what would you say to
someone like so who says that um
subjective experience requires biology
I mean it's a coherent hypothesis that
we don't know what the physical basis of
conscious is one view is this biological
another view is informational and then
there are other views besides I'm very
strongly inclined
towards the informational View
partly because the structure of
Consciousness I find seems to be so
deeply tied to information processing my
visual Consciousness has a very complex
structure of objects and qualities
located in space it seems to very
closely track the informational
properties of the visual system and it's
just hard to see for me how the biology
is essential for example we can imagine
gradually replacing the biological
components of our visual system by say
silicone chips that play the same role
um keeping the information processing
the same to me is very plausible that
would actually preserve Consciousness we
even have the thought experiment where
you gradually replace every neuron in
the brain by a silicon chip I suppose
soil and others are gonna have to say
that your Consciousness gradually
degrades during this process but I think
it was if it's a good enough
if these silicon chips are good enough
simulations of the neurons that they
actually replicate all the information
processing by far the most plausible
thing is this will replicate the
Consciousness too and if it's possible
that any old silicon system
can be conscious and it looks like that
will refute the biological view that
biology has required fascinating
fascinating and could you also just
touch on why you think Consciousness is
one of the only examples of a strongly
emergent phenomena which is to say not
deducible from truths in the lower level
domain I know we touched on this when we
spoke last time but I would love to just
get like a slightly fresher perspective
it's not going to be fresh I'm sorry
because this is a very old issue for me
uh nothing obviously nothing I can say
about this will be fresh okay but um
um
you know most of the things most of the
phenomena we try to explain in the world
are matters of structure and and
function and when it comes to say
explaining life
we need to explain how it is a system
can reproduce how it can adapt how it
can metabolize how it can grow these are
all kind of functional questions
analogous to the easy problems of
Consciousness and those are perfectly
well suited for explanation and physical
terms because physics gives you a
complicated story of structure
and of Dynamics but when it comes to
Consciousness it looks like we have to
explain something that goes beyond
structure function Dynamics we've got
this those are the easy problems when it
comes to Consciousness we also have this
hard problem subjective experience
it seems even once you explain the
structure of the function the Dynamics
of the cognitive system there's still
this further question why subjective
experience I think what makes it unique
is it's not really a question about
structure and function at all so yeah I
think some people who believe in a
global workspace think that is somehow
essential through Consciousness maybe
that's what someone like Joshua bengio
thinks
um I heard you on the Clinton say once
yeah we got to uh
powerful enough systems that didn't need
this low capacity workspace then maybe
we wouldn't need Consciousness anymore
okay and there I think the thought is
they're somehow time conscience by
definition to slow processing in a low
capacity system to system but I'd be
more inclined they would still have
subjective experience it would just be
very fast and Rich yeah yeah I mean
there's already a debate between people
about how fast and rich is conscious you
know poorer and slow Consciousness poor
and slow and fast and Rich I'm kind of
on the side where it's already pretty
fast and pretty rich it feels like that
uh it feels like that for people yeah I
suppose actually relates to one of my
um well I guess the next question which
is I just heard I heard recently talking
about animal ethics and talking about
insect Consciousness it just hadn't
really occurred to me that any other
animals might have a faster rate or even
a richer Consciousness than people might
but I I just heard it sort of speculated
that well insects might have insects my
you know but maybe it's it's the way
that their brains are smaller and
neurons are closer together that means
they might actually have a richer and
deeper experience than we do an
individual land would have a human being
I don't think I've heard that one before
that's it was the first time I'd heard
it what do you think about I've heard
suddenly people saying by sheer weight
of numbers the number of insects in the
world means that insect Consciousness
to making sure our insects don't suffer
[Music]
um yeah I haven't heard the uh the
reasoning in favor of individual insects
being more conscious it has been like
this so simple and integrated maybe that
there are Consciousness has a certain
Purity yeah I guess I guess it is
related to these Notions of integration
and and speed and messages are being
sent and singles being processed I I I
know zero Neuroscience to to actually
substantiate anything else my colleague
Jeff sibo is tinyapple Center NYU on uh
we saw the NYU talks you introduced it
one of the special leads is going to be
non-human countries in animals okay and
his real specialty is insects yeah so I
think there's gonna be a lot of focus on
on insect Consciousness there great uh
and I guess if I can ask one more
um given your personal you know Credence
probability estimates like do you think
there are significant ramifications for
studying Ai and and how how researchers
go forward like to
studying probing deploying language but
you're talking about sort of ethical and
safety issues yeah I mean yeah there's a
million I mean there's a million very
familiar issues that already arise for
any human level AI whether it's
conscious or not yeah
um you know you've got to make very sure
it's going to be aligned with our goals
otherwise it's going to be so powerful
that it's going to have the ability to
bring about whatever it wants to bring
about so we've got to make sure it wants
to bring about the right things I guess
one question is
whether Consciousness changes that in
any fundamental way right I'm not sure
that it fundamentally changes the
questions of say of our safety which may
work the same with other the systems are
conscious or not it does add a whole new
moral Dimension which is worrying about
the AI systems themselves it turns out
that we're building AI systems already
which are conscious yeah then we may
need to consider well how are we
training them does it turn out that
every time they get I mean every time
they back propagate they're actually
suffering yeah yeah
I certainly don't rule that out then
yeah that would be a potentially a moral
disaster and even if they're not
conscious yet if they're going to be
conscious in say 10 years could it be
that in building these more
sophisticated language models where
producing an enormous amount of of
suffering I mean I think this is the
case where I think we want to have
better theories with a better Theory Of
Consciousness we might also have better
theories of like of the basis of certain
kinds of Consciousness like affective
Consciousness suffering and so on
perhaps that could be used to try to uh
you know organize the way we use these
systems certainly
so you know the negative States they go
through or or minimize but that's a bit
of a pipe dream at the moment I think
the uh you know the ethical consequences
are fairly enormous I'm not myself and
ethicist but
um I do hope that as an emphasis think
pretty seriously about these issues sure
actually Jeff Sandra at NYU is going to
be thinking a lot about exactly these
issues the moral consequences of
Consciousness in AI systems as well as
as animals it sounds like that's an
issue uh interested enough certainly I
mean I care
um a lot about safety of systems and
it's mainly why I work on explainability
is because I think this is
instrumentally useful for what sort of
thing are you doing with explainability
yeah um a few there are really so many
angles uh some of the work we were
presenting here is focused on
supervising model explanations for tasks
so you might get a model's doing some
complicated task it gives some kind of
explanation of Its Behavior to you and
what we're doing is is lining those
explanations up with human explanations
for the same task so you're trying to
get the model to behave in a more
human-like way and
um it gets get roughly towards like
aligning its own behavior and reasoning
particularly with human reasoning yeah
so this is actually changing the
processing and the model that's right
that's right more and more explainable
yeah not just giving feedback at the the
final output where it's like correct or
incorrect but trying to supervise the
features and reasoning process that it
doesn't work too yeah and you take a hit
in performance no no it improves
performance it improves generalization
because you specifically want to come up
with tests where it's the only way
you're going to generalize successfully
is by using the correct reasoning
process that a human would so it
improves performance okay yeah yeah
that's good is this true in general and
uh explainability work or uh there's
sort of a performance hip there's kind
of a discussion
um a lot of terms get thrown around you
know there's this post-hoc
explainability approach which the idea
is to you know apply it to any model and
you don't have to change the objective
you don't have to change the training
you don't have to worry about losing
performance there's another basically
camp at this point that is uh you know
suggesting the postdoc isn't enough what
we need to do is change the training and
maybe you do list a bit of a little bit
of performance because you're
constraining the optimization you don't
just care about tax performance you care
about this additional objective the
objectives have to trade off a little
bit uh then maybe you lose performance
um I I think I think the like debate at
high level is like kind of interesting
but for any particular problem
um it's it's it's like
well I guess what
the the I guess the point I really want
to make is like the the debate's like a
little too high level like the actual
details of the problems don't match up
well to this like General accuracy
intervalent trade-off so what's big and
new and exciting and explainability work
um I think some of the interesting stuff
is getting really low level with
representations and weights and figuring
out for a given representation what is
the encode for
um
the single unit level single neuron
single layer yeah some other side
further as like localization work so you
have a specific behavior in mind you
want to know what component in the model
is responsible for this uh this this
could I would feel it seems like it's a
very very cool project but also them so
limited because so much about the models
are doing is out of a local level uh
right right so you want to build up the
understanding so you might start with
smaller units and then ask this is a
little bit of like Chrysalis circuits uh
research trying to understand what the
brain is doing by looking at what single
neurons are doing what it helps a little
bit you get inside yeah this is my
neuroscience some voxels that are like a
million neurons because you have to you
might need a higher level of granularity
to start with but it turns out to be
really hard to do explainability work at
that yeah so a single layer is somewhere
in between things go in both directions
because it's like okay maybe this entire
layer is responsible for something the
model only has 30 layers one of the
layers is responsible for something so
then you you you might meet in the
middle where it's like these neurons but
also this layer and and you're trying to
you try to exactly Define the scope of
the behavior or the function that is
being carried out yeah it is it is like
there's a lot of analogies to
Neuroscience for because it is like uh
reverse engineering It's a larger Stone
cool that's exciting yeah